yeah check it out man it's your boy Akon
and you already know you can check me
out on the bootleg Kev podcast stay
locked baby
bootleg capture we got a special guest
in here he is a living legend I
appreciate that brother welcome to Akon
acon is here man what's going on hey
first of all I just want to say props to
you man uh I always talk as a radio guy
I always talk about a few errors in
music there was the T-Pain era before
that there was you and and T-Pain was
signed to you and for about seven years
straight it was hard for program
directors to separate music because
y'all are both on every [ __ ] song man
right right every hook every song it was
Akon or T-Pain it was just man so salute
to you man no thank you man I remember
um do you remember the rap phenomenon
remix to your ghetto record that like
Green Lantern did yeah
me too oh my God that [ __ ] was crazy
yeah man that was that yeah your first
albums uh I mean I was I was hooked just
right away locked up with such a special
record man so that's what's up welcome
man uh so you uh tell me because you've
kind of been doing so much outside of
the music space
um what has inspired you to drop new
music actually you know what
um the first go around it was more about
the business of the music for me okay so
I was more focused on the business and I
didn't get a chance to really enjoy it
right you know like I'd enjoy it it was
all business but I said the second time
around I want to be able to really enjoy
it man take it breathe it in and enjoy
it all of this luxury that you know we
work for because it don't even make
sense man and then I watched the younger
generation how to get this blessing to
make this many opportunities and
millions around the things that they do
and they just out here killing
themselves yeah yeah it's like what is
the purpose like to do all that to get
out the hood just to bring the hood with
you also like uh it's probably different
now because you're doing it just because
you want to not because you have to
right so when you first got in the music
industry you're like this is my way out
yeah yeah sure so you got to treat it as
such a good job it's a bigger difference
and then you know like the way I feel
like about you know about the life now
is like okay cool I made some good money
Investments are all secured my legacy is
in a good place it's like okay now I can
really go back into the music and have
fun but then again I kind of miss the
music too because it's been I didn't
realize how much time I flew past when's
the last time you dropped a single 2008
was the last time I dropped the record
is that Smack That
no the last one was beautiful okay okay
okay I remember that record yep that was
the last a long time it's been a minute
that's 14 years yeah I mean you hopped
it like you know hopped on people's
stuff you know here and there yeah you
know some collabs here and there but
that's wild that is crazy bro that is
pretty crazy 14 years man I got a 17
year old see how I'm talking about yeah
that [ __ ] is wild that is crazy
obviously you're a very smart you're you
know I think um we're gonna get to like
just your accolades it's just not only
just the artist but you're you know I
think you're one of the when we talk
about CEOs eyes for talent you're one of
them ones um how would you say since
2008 what have been the biggest things
about the music industry that has I know
obviously Tick Tock streaming all that
but just in terms of like you know from
when you first got into the game then
now is there anything that you dislike
about the current uh for like like music
forecast
um anything that I dislike about the
music forecast honestly the only thing
that I can probably say that uh would
put a negative stamp on is the
originality yeah I just think there's
not enough Variety in hip-hop like
everything sound the same this is true
that's the only thing that I dislike
about it but I love the hustle
um I love the opportunity that that the
hip top is bringing to everybody else I
love the um
you know it's it's literally taking well
should take [ __ ] out the hood but
it's it's creating opportunities that we
didn't have before for sure because
before it was either it was either it
was either music or basketball right
right
okay now basketball's still regulated so
you can't just jump into that later yeah
you got to be like a writer an alien
level athlete
music anybody can do it it don't even
matter like you can just any anybody can
just go in the room now and just get on
you know GarageBand and make a record
and go to straight to SoundCloud and go
straight up to SoundCloud because when
you got signed did you get signed off of
a demo tape which was kind of like back
in the day I got I got actually signed
out of creating demos wow which is
interesting because I started off as a
producer songwriter first and I would
write songs for other artists right so
at one point you know they heard my
record was like man it's a dope record I
would love him to write for all right
for our artist but who's the guy singing
on the songs right who's that you know
what I mean and that's how I got pretty
much discovered you kind of Came Out
Swinging with a record like locked up
which is
when you first come out with a song like
Locked Up featuring Styles P right
and you you you're very like you said
originality when you first came onto the
scene no one sounded like Akon Nobody
that's why I was so hard to get that
record played like locked up was out a
whole year before I got styles on it wow
like you know MTV thought it was too
Urban and BT said it wasn't Urban enough
so I was stuck in the middle it was
nowhere to go so then when Styles got
locked up it was like wait hold up
he can actually and he had the Streets
back then you know oh yeah for sure all
the mixtapes people like all that yeah
and I actually reached out to a lot of
other features before even Styles right
and some either evil either charged me
way too much or just said they couldn't
do it they wouldn't do it because the
record just wasn't you know it was it
was to them it was an r b record so when
Styles you know offered to do the record
he had actually heard it and loved the
record already and was like man I would
love to do it so he's the one I give
credit for helping me break that record
yeah I mean once he became on there
right it became Urban automatic yeah it
became like a rap record right even
though like I feel like you're kind of
like one of those artists who I just
look at as like like an artist you're
not a rapper you're sick you sing
obviously but you're kind of like you
know when people put a title on future
post Malone is Like Rappers I'm like nah
they're just artists who just make good
music right right it might be hip hop
some of this just pop you know I'm
curious because at your Peak as an
artist when you were extremely active
you were like the go-to hookman right
everybody had to have an acon hook you
had you gave people careers there was
people who was getting deals or getting
bags just because they had you on a hook
right
um what was the biggest bag you got to
do a hook
um well actually mine when it come to
hook bags it was a little different
because every song you ever heard me on
that half the hook on it was a record I
produced so I would give them the beat
with me already on the chorus so they
had to pay for both they had to pay for
the whole thing so like because there's
been a lot of um artists who have done
songs that like clearly they did for the
bag was there one of those for you where
you were like yo this bag was so crazy
the song might have been I might not
have loved the artist but the song it
was bad you know what's interesting
in the beginning there was one record
that I can recall started with a bag and
then I was so happy I did it because the
relationship came out it was amazing it
was Baby Bash oh I love that record you
know that because I before I did that
record I had never heard of Baby Bash
baby I'm back man yeah baby I'm back I
never heard that song and it was
interesting because once I was like okay
cool this is some good money so I did it
but then when I met him we connected I
was like damn glad I did this record
baby he's such a cool dude he's like the
coolest guy ever coolest dude in the
[ __ ] world yeah I said so I was like
man I'm so happy we connected this way
you know then I felt bad because I was
like if I'd known this I would never
charge them yeah it's crazy because at
that time you probably aren't hip to
what he's doing right the Latin world is
so different it was so different first
major label debut right you know he came
off that Frankie J record right yeah
Cyclone Baby I'm back yeah yeah he
tapped in with convict music for sure
for that first hour you know because
right after that we send them over to
T-Pain and got another record yeah 100
it's crazy because I talked to Payne and
he had told me that you had offered him
a record deal super early and he said
that uh a major label came and offered
him like a substantially crazier amount
of money they did
but he said I I trusted Akon I believed
in his movement to and he's like I'm
living out my car me and my girl are
struggling he's like and I passed on the
bag with this major situation and stuck
with Akon and signed the deal for less
money because of his vision because of
all the things that you bring to the
table that money can't buy like uh what
was it about pain obviously he was in a
group called uh was it the Nappy Heads
yeah robbery is my [ __ ] by the way
that's a Tampa classic
um but uh what was it about paying that
like initially kind of struck your
interest and had you kind of take a
chance on him and he also took a chance
on you no he did I mean till his day I
thank him for just believing in me
because that kind of changed your label
he was the first artist I signed on
right he was like literally the first
artist so it was not only because he was
the first artist that I had to prove for
future artists that I plan to sign but
because he took the chance on me I made
sure that I put whatever I had in him
like because I I gave him a promise that
I'm give you a career I said I know they
could give you a bag but I'm gonna give
you a career I'm gonna give you a career
and I made sure that that happened for
him until this day I still fight for him
even though he's often doing his own
thing I always will always be in debt to
T-Pain for sure yeah pop pop the
conflict music off the label as a label
yeah no without a doubt it was our
franchise player you also who I mean
obviously Lady Gaga yeah but see Gaga
was on Khan live at the time I had two
labels check you out I had con live
which was the pop label and then I had
convict music which was the urban label
there's always speculation are you still
getting money off of Lady Gaga no no not
no more not no more how many albums in
was it before the bag stopped I had it
for four albums Christ you had it for
four albums so after the four albums the
deal is over but then did she have four
albums nah she never got to four
so you eventually were like hey look
well at that time it was a lot of moving
parts
and I kind of seen where the future was
going because of how the parts were
moving and that's when I made a deal
for
my portion and steak of her and I bought
out I sold out oh so you sold your
portion of whatever she doesn't matter
right before the dip oh that's smart do
you think that that's why artists are
currently selling their catalog right
now like they're publishing because they
feel like it's a depreciating asset
maybe
um no I think a lot of them are are
selling for because they don't know they
don't I don't think they know the value
of what that is they're selling yeah
because I saw like future sell like a
ridiculous amount of titles for like 75
million a lot of people were like yo he
probably should have got more well
actually
yeah that many like future I think you
could have got definitely more for for
the amount of titles he sold out yeah
um but sometimes they look at it
differently like when you're coming from
the street you're looking at how you can
flip the 75 million right so maybe he
has some other [ __ ] that line up future
ain't stupid like of course smart guy
and I'm sure he's like okay cool
I can go and pull this away because just
people don't really even know that that
interest just on that 75 million he
could live forever not have work work
ever again yeah if you manage your money
properly put that Park that money in
certain you know Ventures you'll never
have that money pays for your lifestyle
forever literally
so now everything you make on this side
is bonus strip club money that's
beautiful you know what was was it a
comparable bag for your Lady Gaga buy
out it was enough to for me to retire
I hadn't made a record since until now
that's crazy so would you say that like
obviously being a part of Lady Gaga's
career being able to capitalize off that
you took a chance on her early Just
Dance Poker Face all that [ __ ] is it was
worth it it was worth every painting
she's another one that I treat like
T-Pain I'm always and forever be there
for how was your uh how was your current
relationship with her oh same same yeah
yeah what was it about her because I
feel like when she first came into the
game
I don't think we really understood how
talented she was because she wasn't
necessarily diving into the type of
records that fully show us her her
potential yeah her range right right so
what was it about what you saw in her
early on that like you know you were
like oh yeah nah yeah well the thing is
I had already recognized all of that and
I was like man if she get the chance to
be able to express herself as a real
artist and not be pushed left or right
for a label telling her what she can and
cannot do she's gonna be out of here wow
because she's she's the kind of person
that creates like movements and I saw
that as we was promoting her and how she
was creating that monster movement in
itself I was like oh this is big all we
gotta do now just let her do her yeah I
think that's what happened with the
second album right yeah first album was
like kind of like the first album was
push more between me and red one giving
her the sound that we felt can break her
through and it worked and it worked and
then the second album was really more
her taking over saying okay thank you
guys for the you know training wheels
now I'm gonna go just because like was
bad romance on the second album I was on
the first oh it was on the first oh well
[ __ ] that's one of my favorite songs
yeah shout out to Lady Gaga yeah she's a
legend man that's a joke man she's a
legend without a doubt yeah it's pretty
crazy if you think of like Lady Gaga
T-Pain everyone's career you've been
involved in it's been uh who else was on
your [ __ ] was Kobe dinosaur yeah Kobe
was there he was actually supposed to
have been well he was the first Justin
Bieber put it that way no I remember I
remember doing um when I was an intern I
did a high school mix tour with him
right it was so crazy man we just did
but you know his dad was there and I
just remember his dad being a [ __ ]
weirdo
I remember being like yo that Kobe kid's
cool as [ __ ] but his Pop's kind of
strange
unfortunately his father was the reason
for his downfall and I hate to say it
out loud but unfortunately that was the
only thing his father his father's very
overzealous and kind of lived him him
his his dream right yeah because he has
some dope records yeah so I think he
still I think he's still writing records
or something was
man till that's the only only project
knowing what I know today I would have
moved differently um I know that at the
time I would have definitely went back
and forth with the pops but because it
was Father and Son you don't really want
to get in the middle of blood when it
comes to money yeah she could get weird
I would have definitely intervened had I
known it would have ended up the way it
did that's yeah I get that uh what you
know there's certain artists um
correct me if I'm wrong but you and Jay
never did anything together no me and
Jay never worked together was there ever
just crazy it is crazy it's not like
even me I'm like how I've worked with
every artist in the globe except Jay-Z
until this day I don't know why it never
got close to happening it never was even
inquired wow because the thing is I
think I think it was the the timing in
each other's careers because at the time
when I was in at Peak musically and
moving some way he was moving to the
executive side executive right deaf jam
and I think it was that timing at the
moment when I'm going this way he's
going this way yeah he'd rather have you
do a record for one of his artists right
I think yeah yeah because at that time I
was producing records for Def Jam and
all that I even got to the point where
my brother was in Def Jam at the same
time so it was like I think it was but I
don't until his day I never understood
why that never happened yeah I mean
because yeah you got records with
everybody else right [ __ ] I never
understood that yeah you gave Eminem one
of his best club records he's ever
I feel like smack that's a song that
like still gets played no it is at like
[ __ ] 11 p.m at whatever Club you guys
but see and it was interesting because
every record I ever put out I actually
produced except smack that really who
Did That Eminem produced that record I
miss Eminem when he was isn't that crazy
I missed I missed the Eminem producer
era when he was producing a lot of his
own [ __ ] yeah I know his Beats weren't
the craziest but his Beats were like
very distinct you heard it right and you
knew his sound it knew it right right
and I'm like oh that's dope M's at least
got his own remember he was doing uh he
was he produced Renegade right he
produced uh the cross for Nas on God's
son yeah he produced a lot of dope [ __ ]
but I don't know I think he got I don't
know if he got away from it or maybe I'm
tripping or he'd stop sounding like that
but I feel like the last album had a lot
of his own [ __ ] that I was like oh
that's what I was missing from him he
always had it's always some small little
sounds I think dude it was something
minute that you just it was I think it
was like it felt like Eminem I was like
oh this Eminem beat I could tell yeah
100 m m has some heat rocks that day
what up y'all we gotta stop the
interview to tell you about our new
sponsors our family at hardeen Las Vegas
you see what it is you see what it is
welcome to the family heart Dean man
we're so excited I've been going to
Hardy for so many years for people who
don't know Hardin is that premium
cannabis dispensary the number one
award-winning dispensary in Las Vegas
I'm talking the biggest and best
selection of cannabis product and of
course in Vegas but I'm talking about
worldwide they're them [ __ ] all
right so what you got to do is pull up
when you're in Vegas to hardine go to
Harding underscore Las Vegas shoot them
that follow on Instagram go see them
tell them I sent you when you go to
check out be like yo bootleg Kev sent me
I saw y'all talking about it on a
bootleg cat podcast look when you're in
Vegas they'll also deliver right to your
room whatever you need all right make
sure you follow the crew Harding
underscore loss Vegas go to
hardinlasvegas.com that's
j-a-r-d-i-n Las vegas.com and don't
forget when you go to Vegas you go to
Jardin tell them I sent you and then
only might throw a little extra little
eighth in the bag or something a little
discount the bootleg discount you know
what I'm saying get them backwards too
they give me a Packwood the other day
that jeez I'm still recovering from that
[ __ ] blew my whole [ __ ] face off in
the best way Hardy in Las Vegas all
right shout out to them let's get back
to the interview uh okay talk to me
about your your crypto project
a coin now just help me understand
because I think a lot of people
are down on crypto in general right nfts
have taken a [ __ ] right the whole entire
whole Market fell well the whole entire
space is like it felt a little predatory
right right so I feel like you've gotten
some uh negative feedback for your
project explain your project and why it
is obviously is it still going on is
this that's the thing Acorn is African
coin okay so most of the things that's
that's happening in the US it doesn't
really affect us because we have our own
currency and mine was turning Mobile
minutes into currency because out there
you have to buy your minutes still right
yeah so it's a whole nother concept
whole number you know like our exchange
rate for minutes don't even exist in
America like because they don't you
can't turn your Mobile minutes into
actual spending money here yeah because
bandwidth in Africa is like less it's so
much less but a lot of people don't know
that cell phones have been operating in
Africa since 96. which way before he was
even operating America like they so
Advanced when it comes to mobile and the
the
um the kind of Technology you have to
mobile carriers is just on a different
level so your your coin if somebody has
a phone plan in Africa and maybe they
don't use 100 minutes for the month
exactly they can convert those minutes
for groceries exactly wow that's dope
yeah so it's totally different but now
we're converting the wallet to where you
can be able to use it in the states and
I'll be launching that before the end of
the year oh that's dope and now what
about just the city that everyone says
you're building wakanda yeah it was a
condo
no I'm just joking it's a con City but I
play on that because the movie kind of
actually believe it or not the movie did
a lot for acon City because people never
knew that Africa could even be or could
look like that not realizing that we
were already in process of building a
smart City already before the movie so
before the movie came out you were
already in the world concept since 2010.
wow yeah but we just we literally just
starting the construction that's
beautiful man that's a serious thing to
build a city
like how do you get the funding for that
besides Lady Gaga
it's more of the preparation though
right you know so when you start dealing
with all these major developers globally
and then you start dealing with the
studies like from the Environmental
Studies all the way down to soil studies
hey you're going to have sewage you
gotta have a trash compartments all that
stuff me I learned so much in the
process of this I mean building a house
is one thing but when you're talking
about building the city the
infrastructure that's attached to that
is on a different level then we're
talking about smart city with technology
that people don't even know exists yet
right you know so it was what technology
doesn't exist yet oh wait I can't wait
to invite you out of the city okay
a lot of it I got to keep under close
NDA conversations but for the most part
when y'all finally are invited it's
gonna be a treat well everyone get
internet oh yeah that's what I'm saying
yeah
everyone will have internet that's what
I'm saying that's beautiful how many
square miles one square mile one square
mile so it'll be very small communities
it starts off but it is set up to where
it could scale out wow yeah that's dope
man yeah well salute to you man you know
I'm excited about it though [ __ ] I'm
trying to go no you will you mean you're
heavily gonna be there obviously it's
somebody who uh never really made
afrobeats but to see as an African
um to see it be I mean I I just talked
to somebody last night a burner boy was
the number one song in urban radio and
it got overtaken by Thames right see
which is so fire right so far man
um how dope is it just to see afrobeat
be like uh the new just it's kind of
like what everyone's doing even if
you're not from like it's just the it's
just music now it's not African music
yeah and that was one of my pop music
fights yeah yeah one of our biggest
fights was just introducing it into the
you know into the world and then once it
was introduced okay don't quite
generalize it because I remember when we
first you know I remember back when I
was trying to um shop Wizkid over at
Sony and it was like 2000 10.
if people don't know whiz kids like a OG
everybody thought it was I mean they
thought it was reggae music right but at
that time it wasn't no information so
you didn't you never really knew but
ultimately it was always a fight but
then when it worked in the UK it opened
up the door and then when YouTube became
super popular
that's what did it social media and
YouTube is what opened the doors for
afrobeat to actually shine yeah cause
YouTube is the biggest uh platform
people consume music on in Africa right
it's there and uh I think it's Audiomack
is there too because it doesn't take a
lot of bandwidth yeah Audi Max is
different it's huge in Africa yeah so
you were [ __ ] with uh Wizkid in 2010
yeah was he signed to you or were you
just helping him out I signed him in
2008. so you signed whiskey in 08 yeah
that's crazy here back in the way to con
liver to convict no that's that's
convict Africa wow so how well explain
it because now he's a he's a global
Superstar oh he's super super gold uh so
you sign him
um obviously he was probably buzzing
where he's from like how did you guys
initially meet and what ended up what
ended up happening well so what happened
was when we when I went to Africa after
the World Cup we were looking for ways
that we can take the local music and
Branch it off right so at that time it
was the local music was so traditional
musically that it wouldn't break outside
of Nigeria Ghana anywhere right so we
started adding like commercialized music
and music like instruments around it
like we commercialized a lot of it so it
went from afrobeat to afro pop wow
basically yeah you follow so once we did
that then we signed we signed it was kit
first then after that was another group
called P-Square okay P-Square was two
twins that came out of Nigeria they
ended up becoming the poster Childs of
Africa at that time as a group they were
the biggest streaming selling all of
that but that was all of us pushing that
point wow as that went more popular
Wizkid as a solo artist just became
bigger and bigger because he had the the
whole
um fell off Vibe like the younger
generation swag wow you know so as I
started moving everything else started
branching as we went as we were signing
acts and pushing them over then it was
like okay soon now that this is huge in
Africa let's start chopping it and
chopping It in America right and that's
when all the other records started
coming about but we just couldn't get
the Us labels to catch they didn't get
it yet you were ahead of your time yeah
they didn't get it you know they didn't
they really kind of took the UK hopping
on board and then I really feel like I
played a huge role when Drake did one
dance because Drake was so heavily
influenced about what was going on in
the UK and afrobeats but I feel like one
dance made like um America okay with the
sound they're like oh Drake did you know
what I mean I feel like labels look at
[ __ ] in the shallow way like that yeah
the labels probably looked at the
success of the one dance with Drake and
then but Drake was on yeah yeah Drake
already knew how big it was that's why
he did in the first place like he
already knew what it was so what ended
up having to happen with you and Wiz
Kids so so ultimately right now Wiz is
no longer signed to us okay but we're
still Affiliates and work all his
records internationally along with
Sunday at what point in time did you
guys split on the label side um Ten
Years After wow like 2018. oh [ __ ] yeah
that's not I think I interviewed him in
2018. yeah it's right around the corner
I think he was on my show there if he
was in LA he was the reason why he got
here oh wow that's crazy that was that
was his first run in in the U.S are you
still getting a piece of Wizkid pause no
no no no no no no
no no but but the kind of relationship
we have with all of our artists even
after they're no longer on the label we
still bring work and there's still
commission from it so I always try to
keep a relationship to where it's not a
a boss employee type of you know
relationship it's always been a
partnership yeah and oftentimes there's
certain things that we as convict music
just do better than anybody else so they
always come to us for certain services
and we always be attached to them okay
take me back let's say hypothetically
I'm an independent rapper I happen to be
a drug dealer I got stupid money money's
not a problem right I'm a rapper in 2004
2005. and I'm like yo I hit up convict
music I'm like I need the Akon special I
need the song I need the hook I need
everything right what do you hitting me
upside the head for 200 000. 200 000.
now does that increase if it's a major
label it's 200 000 with this major or
not wow 200k the price didn't change
plus you get your Pub oh yeah I mean you
get everything you're supposed to get
that's just for our services that's
amazing 200k you're doing a lot of those
oh we did a lot of those what was the
busiest year you had the busiest year
was oh I mean years the busiest years
was from 2005 to 2009. wow five good
years that's crazy yeah yeah you had it
man did you ever hear that from Radio
programmers they've completed everyone I
went to I mean I remember they had
created even this I don't know if it was
a law but it was the system it was
whatever you're about to say it was a
real thing I didn't know it was like an
Akon rule right they're like okay you
can't play uh I want to say was a kind
of T-Pain you can't yeah you can't play
it was 100 a thing right oh I didn't
even know that because they're because
because back in the day there used to be
artist separation when people would
program the logs for a radio station and
at one point in time it was you and pain
and then once the Wayne [ __ ] really took
off it kind of all intersected and then
it was like there's no way this is
possible we can't it just didn't make
sense and then [ __ ] T-Pain and Wayne
around got money together and that's
just a double [ __ ] you to program
directors because it's like how do we
program this [ __ ] song they're both
on it right they both know it is crazy
it was [ __ ] crazy man uh what so tell
me about smack that because you said
that that's the only song that dropped
it you didn't produce did Eminem send
you that beat no no actually when I went
to visit m in Detroit he was like so how
you what you want to do I see him I want
to do whatever you want to do I want you
I want to come into your world like yeah
because if I bring into my world it
won't be no different from what's out
there now right he's like all right well
you know I got some beats I said [ __ ]
you produce he said yeah I said well
play me some tracks he gave me a photo
with like 30 tracks on it and out of the
30 I picked five and out of five I
recorded all five but the one that stood
out smack that smack that yeah yeah I
was like bro this is are you I was gonna
say are you still actively doing the
production thing oh yeah that's yeah
that never changed you know like a lot
of the records that you got that you're
hearing out now we got something to do
it you and Eminem here smack that it
gets laid down are you there when he
records his verses um well actually once
he heard my concept to it then he was
like yo I'm jumping on this one yeah and
I said you know what if he jumps on this
one this is the single oh it was the
same
and sure because that was your record
right that wasn't his record yeah yep it
was my record yeah do you guys had more
than one record or just one that's the
only one we had together yeah besides
the other five that didn't yeah but I
still have them oh wow that's like I
literally still have those records today
is there any songs that never dropped
that you have on a hard drive that you
were like man if this would ever came
together the right way those are all the
records that's gonna drop in the future
like did I that I'm promoting now these
are all records that was recorded that I
knew for a fact was Smash Hits but I
didn't want it was reasons why I didn't
drop them at that time and the time and
also made a difference too also like you
make Timeless records so it doesn't
matter it don't even matter but if you
turn on the radio right now you might
hear I want to love you or you might
want to you might hear I mean [ __ ] maybe
I'm back where it depends on what part
of the country you're definitely gonna
hear Soul Survivor no for sure yeah yeah
do you I feel like Soul Survivor did so
much for Jeezy because obviously had and
then what which I think was the first
single off team 101 yeah
um but it was like it was it was a dope
Club record dope Street record but to me
Soul Survivor just changed the whole
narrative because there was this guy who
everyone knew was the street rapper he
was in boys in the hood right and he he
had an undeniable hit record like Soul
Survivor is probably one of my favorite
hooks you've ever done like that record
a special man no it is special and you
made the beat yep that beats crazy
that's one of your best beats too
deniably that shit's hard yeah it's one
of them once
yo it's bootleg Kev here to tell you
about our partners at my bookie damn it
football season we're in the thick of it
right now I hit big last week too man I
want to give a shout out to uh to my guy
who gave me the picture out my guy
sports book Killer but listen what you
got to do is go to my bookie right now
get in on this NFL action you know NBA
is coming up too you could bet on
anything you want they got the player
props you could do the a parlay Builder
you could bet on your favorite team to
win the Super Bowl get them odds up
whatever it is the most important thing
get that first time deposit bonus that
means when you sign up for your account
use the promo code bootleg
b-o-o-t-l-e-g and you will get a deposit
match so if you put in 200 they're gonna
give you 200 on top of that to gamble
with for free if you put in a thousand
dollars they're gonna match that deposit
with a free thousand dollars for you to
gamble with right now so what the [ __ ]
are you waiting for let's get this money
let's watch some [ __ ] football and
let's get paid with my bookie help me
out so as you can see I shave my head in
the same way you've shaved your head all
these years right what's up with the
hair what are we doing here how can I
get the Akon
what do I got to go to you gotta grow it
out just a little bit more because you
know I got I got this [ __ ] Eminem
hairline
my dad's bald as [ __ ] so I don't go to
the barber I just go to my bathroom and
I just shave my head twice a week I
haven't shaved in about a week and a
half but like uh you obviously have hair
right yeah it was so so oh no I went to
Turkey I went to Turkey and got a
procedure was it painful don't forget in
the beginning my whole front was loose
it was real thin was it painful nah no
no it's the painful part is the
beginning when they gotta numb you up
that numbing ain't no joke what they
speak a needle like this big this is
non-stop like did they do the graph
thing where they take a picture so
that's what they did yeah they took the
draft because your [ __ ] looks good it
looks like it looks amazing yeah I love
it like Tory Lanez should have went to
your guy I told a [ __ ] I said Victoria
should have came to my man
yeah bro you gotta get up
and turkey's known for turkey no turkey
is known for two things that's hair and
teeth they're really good and also being
terrible towards Armenia shout out to my
Armenian family I love my Armenian
brothers and sisters out there but yeah
they are known people go out there get
their teeth done or they get their hair
done yep but hair is they specialize in
hair people are getting beards now yeah
I mean beer is the whole night Floyd got
the uh you know the oh cause me I can't
grow hair on my face me either like I
can't I go facial hair like a 12 year
old it's terrible it's bad dude my son
like legitimately my son's 17 he's half
Mexican so he's hairy right that
[ __ ] has way more facial hair
than me it's embarrassing in my own
house
in my own house it was a hairier male in
my own house that's too funny and I
gotta go to Turkey to get my [ __ ] right
I gotta get your guys number the face is
right though I'll connect you for sure
was it expensive nah that's the thing
it's so affordable it's ridiculous yeah
I was about to say but without for what
I did it would have cost me 50 Grand
here in America
8 7 500. that's it that's it are you
worried about like paying 7 500 for
something so serious when you have the
money to do the 50. no because here they
over charging anything related to health
care or any kind of medical procedure
America I mean they tag on 10 times
because I think some people might be
like well Akon you're rich why not just
I'm not mad I work hard for this money
I'm not I don't care
yeah it's yeah that's bad you do because
think about it even the teeth procedures
over there here the same job that people
are paying 40 50 grand for they they
charge you 500 7 500 I go to Tijuana and
go to the this because I work for myself
so I don't have insurance so I just go
to TJ get some Mexican food get my teeth
worked on you got veneers the fronts
yeah yeah it's all veneers that that was
that painful no no that was simple you
just woke up from the numbing and you
were like [ __ ] look at me yeah easy so
there's uh obviously the singles out but
are you um you're obviously preparing a
new album as well yeah the album's I
can't wait I can't wait any features you
can uh that's the thing because I've
been having so many features on my
albums this album is it's less features
right but the ones that's on there makes
all the sense in the world I'm wondering
all the sense in the world you have
the type of records that were so played
out right which song of yours do you
hate the most because it was just so
played out the thing is I don't hate any
of my records how about not hate but
just the song that you're the most tired
of the one the one song that I've heard
so much to the point where I can do
without hearing it today yeah it will
probably be SmackDown I feel you it
would probably be no like everywhere I
go hear it and then when I walk into any
establishment yeah they're like oh [ __ ]
he's here play it he wrote the smack
that you have to smack that because it's
a club record I'm sure am probably tired
of hearing it too because I'm sure he
get it the same I really legitimately
think that might be Eminem's on the club
song that like he had that one in the
Nate Dogg record uh what was the Nate
Dogg record he had that was like uh uh
the Nate Dogg [ __ ] was it shake shake
shake that shake that ass for me yeah
that was it yeah cause all his other
records were more storytelling yeah no
one's playing Just Lose It In the Club
yeah that's true depending on which club
you go to they might drop
Lose Yourself if there's a lot of white
folks in there just to get them to sing
along to something right as a matter of
fact because he was more of a like a
Lyricist and then he told a lot of
stories so you'll get more play from him
on a video channel than you would in the
club I want to [ __ ] you another classic
oh yeah shout out to Snoop shot I
remember when that song first came out I
had no idea that it was dirty because I
was just so used to the radio right to
the radio and then when I got the album
I was like oh [ __ ] that was on blue
carpet treatment right wasn't it on blue
carpet treatment no that was on uh it
was on a convicted album okay okay but
but I what I did I cleared it so he can
have it on his album because it was it
shared it yeah no that was one of those
ones man it was one of ones and you did
the B yeah [ __ ] that's crazy you're a
genius man thank you man I appreciate
that brother speaking of geniuses your
brother has been uh in the past a part
of Kanye's team right shout out to boo
who was a dog music industry Legend in
his own right absolutely he's done a lot
in the business 100 he stood on his own
independent from you which period and
that's that's what I was proud of the
most at first in the beginning I was
like yo boo like I don't get
I've already paid the way for you why
would you want to start over and do it
all from day one right you know his
whole thing was well I didn't want
people just when they see me they
already see Akon's little brother yeah
because you guys are also obviously
Brothers physically yeah physically
brothers so then I you know I said okay
you're right you got that what are your
thoughts on uh this Kanye last couple of
weeks with uh just there's so much in
the last couple of weeks is not
something that surprised me obviously I
mean that's yay
um but I think sometimes you have to
also realize that everybody's not like
him or think like him right so you can't
force your opinions on other people
there's a lot of history that goes with
black and whites in America and there's
so much more that he needs to you know
desensitize himself from and realize
that there's certain things that may not
have affected you but it's affected
other people because real lives were
lost in the process of these actions
right so you can't just say White lives
matter in the case like that
specifically of course everyone knows
that all lives matter but there's a
specific history and I mean America that
just needs to be recognized and
acknowledged because of the history of
black people in this country that's all
it is yeah I think that it's to the
point where it's like we all recognize
that black lives matter is a true
statement right we also can recognize
that the organization might not have did
the best business right but we also have
to recognize that the term White lives
matter is a term that racist people use
right like the roots right but to be
said it's also a true term if you say it
out loud factually yes everyone's lives
matter but at the same time black lives
matter became a slogan because it was
obvious that black lives did not matter
as much as everyone else's right
absolutely and historically in America
if we're being honest I mean listen
historically everywhere man no for sure
you mean the colonization of parts of
your home country yeah I was gonna say
in your home country yeah I heard in
Africa it's still bad in some places
well it's Africa's kind of changing
I don't know if that's for the good
but in certain parts in Africa white
people are in the projects wow and the
black people are in The Mansions I just
stayed that way I mean listen man so it
depends on what size what part of Africa
is that I mean oh that's from South
Africa okay yeah South Africa the way
people now are screaming for equality
which is crazy right pretty crazy it's
like you guys colonizing you guys
colonized South Africa right yeah yeah
the UK is calling you yeah the UK is
like hold up now but there's nothing
they could do because they never left
the UK they just they they literally
claimed it from the UK it started
selling off land that they never even
owned right because they had the weapons
obviously they all powered people but as
the uprisings and everything came they
the Revolt happened and people start
fighting back yeah hey what up y'all
it's bootleg Kev here to stop the
interview sorry uh but we gotta pay the
[ __ ] bills and you know not only do
we have to pay the bills but we also
gotta take care of them [ __ ] out there
that's right make sure you go to
bluetooth.com right now you know the
bootleg kept podcast we are presented by
bluetooth proudly I happen to every once
in a while dabbling a little chooski you
know what I'm saying and let me tell you
something my dick thanks me for it every
single time uh so listen if you go to
Bluetooth use the promo code bootleg
you're gonna get your first month's
supply for free now we're talking the
same active ingredient as Viagra as
Cialis without the awkward doctor's
appointment visit you just go online
they get you taken care of it gets
delivered right to your [ __ ] door in
discreet packaging it's a beautiful
thing and how about this
brand new product alert on Bluetooth all
right and I'm gonna [ __ ] this up for
sure so I'm gonna try to read it uh now
Bluetooth has a mint flavored chewable
with
bardenophil which is the same active
ingredient in Levitra and staxin
so shout out to Levitra
same active ingredient in the mint
flavor chewables so what are we doing go
get you a little mint boy go get you a
little blue chew whatever the [ __ ] you
need just know
whatever young lady or man or Etc that
you're dealing with they're gonna
[ __ ] thank you for it because your
dick's going to be harder than it's ever
been in your whole [ __ ] life man it's
gonna be great and like if you're a
single guy
take a blue chew
jack off
be a better jerk I'll tell you that all
right bluetooth.com go right now
and uh you know I know we have a lot of
male listeners who like underground raps
so chances are you're not getting a lot
of [ __ ] but I promise you one thing you
take that blue chair you're gonna beat
your dick like it stole some all night
long bluetooth.com use that promo code
bootleg right now and they will give you
the first month for free so go do that
[ __ ] I think a lot of things with the
Kanye think people are like a little
shook up about is I saw I don't know if
you saw Maverick Carter just said that
he's uh they he came and recorded an
episode of LeBron show the shop which is
a HBO show right and they decided not to
release it because he was I guess saying
some wild [ __ ] some anti-semitic [ __ ]
you know what I'm saying but you
probably have a better insight to yay
than most people considering how close
in proximity your brother worked for for
people who don't know your brother
management for some time right yeah he
Madison for some time he's not currently
uh managing him now but he does I don't
know if anybody can manage Kanye well
Kanye is unmanageable because he pretty
much managed himself right all you can
do is put barricades to help him protect
him yeah that's the only way that's the
only job of a manager around yay is to
protect him from himself I was going to
say would you can because I think some
people
don't they don't know him like everyone
else does would you say he's like a
generally a good dude no genuinely he's
a really good dude good heart great
intentions
um I just think that
he's in a position where he believes
that his opinion matters in the world
and when you do that and people telling
you well you don't your opinion don't
matter in my life yeah and you're
forcing your opinion to matter in their
life but not getting all the details of
why his opinion don't matter in your
life it can create an issue when you're
too confident
um you know yeah and if you're like so
sure that you're right and everyone else
is wrong exactly it's like that
eliminates any Nuance or discussion to
be had about any particular issue
because you're saying it's my way
because I'm Connie and I'm a [ __ ]
genius because you know without taking
anything from yay he's been through a
whole spiritual journey yeah so he's
seen things that the average man didn't
see like I honestly believe that he's
went through spiritually uh a journey
that average people don't go yeah he
really did but the thing is when you
believe that people understand you the
way you understand you that's a that's
where it becomes an issue yeah because
not everybody understands his position
and when you're trying to so hard to
explain it to people who will never get
it because they have to go through your
journey to get it it becomes an uphill
battle trying to you know and people
have to give you the benefit of the
doubt that you're what you're saying
isn't what you're saying that you have a
bigger message behind it and when you
say certain [ __ ] that he says recently
it's like I don't really care what your
thought process was right right and
you're and you don't care enough really
explain it right exactly so that's when
that's when everyone takes it personal
and then when it goes personal then it's
hard to talk about yeah that's fair uh
okay can you tell us any of the features
on the project you said that they make
sense oh yeah yeah this is I'm going to
kind of as they drop okay yeah I think
that that that that that approach to me
because I want to leave a little bit of
sense of mystery because nowadays social
media allow you to leave no mystery you
know everything before it even happened
you know the video before it even shot
because at the video shoot everybody's
shooting they didn't see the video you
see the behind the scenes yeah so and I
know how everything will be broadcasted
so I said the only thing I can control
that I can at least give something some
some some people something to look
forward to is who's going to be on the
album
how many records
did you cut with Dre for the detox [ __ ]
um because wasn't one of the only
records we got weren't you on yeah
actually the the last two records that
he was putting out for the detoxing
records that I produced or a rodon yeah
I mean and I don't think we're ever
gonna hear the quote-unquote detox but
like I was lucky I was blessed yeah we
heard your [ __ ] two records that I've
you know been released one of them was
the um
um uh I'm so bad with titles it was me
and Snoop and Dre I remember that one I
forget the name of it too wait a minute
yeah kush yeah it was kush and then the
second one was
um Kush was hard what was the other ones
that one was just Dre and Snoop and I
was on the chorus as well on that one I
don't remember the other one I remember
Kush is the one I was thinking of yeah
Kush was a monster that [ __ ] was hard
yeah and it could have like to me
cushion was the type of record because
he did that one and then he tried to put
out the I Need a Doctor record and I was
like oh we're getting singles this
should equal in albums right it just
never happened yeah Dre is just such a
you know perfectionist
I think he's too perfect for himself I
think and it was a lot of fear involved
as to
not being number one as well too like if
he puts the album out and it's not
number one right I think I think they
had a lot to do and again I'm not
speaking for him and I could be
completely wrong yeah but from the
outside looking in it felt like he he
put too much on himself to succeed and
be successful when I thought check
yourself out yeah I believe personally
that he don't need it like he has
nothing to prove to anybody to me is the
greatest producer out of the West Coast
and influencer when it comes to hip-hop
and gangster music yeah that no matter
what he would have dropped everybody
would have thirsted up they'd have took
it in I think when you have the first
two chronics being as perfect as they
were right but that's what I'm saying
like it's like Michael Jackson trying to
outdo Thriller right some projects are
meant to just Embrace a group of people
a certain way and some it may not be
statistically number one for what he may
see it but it may be a body of work that
may incorporate or you can say um uh uh
impact a certain types or certain of
people that might change the world yeah
so every record may do something totally
different I don't change the course of
Music think or change the course of Life
yeah right so when you look at Bob
Marley and his music for instance his
music changed wars in Africa and in the
Caribbeans and also also I was gonna say
later on but those records were number
one on the charts no no but they made
they meant a lot yeah right and I think
Dre has he has to see it from that
standpoint too his records could have
changed the mindset of gangsters yeah
especially this generation yeah because
this generation is [ __ ] up it's
generous as [ __ ] but Dre was actually
kicking a little bit of knowledge in the
midst of all of that like you can
actually get some perspective and I
think when he stopped it kind of changed
the course of the direction of where the
future gangsters were going that's fair
yeah it's rough right now with just all
the violence and yeah it's crazy it's
deep uh yo when we think of we talked
about you we talked about pain there's
been other artists who have had their
runs and been called the new Akon a few
times right guys like Ty Dolla Sign uh
there's just been a few guys who are
like been the Hook guy in hip-hop at the
time it feels like every four or five
years we get a new guy who they compare
to you or paying I love it who do you uh
appreciate just as a fan that you've
just like that that kind of reminds you
of of maybe the early and I don't know
if anybody could ever well actually you
actually mentioned him I love Ty Dolla
Sign yeah he's a legend man I love Ty
dollars and he's a talent like one of
the most talented guys ever I think he's
probably the most underrated
I agree like this dude is so amazing man
like he's so dope and he can switch into
any genre like toss anything in front of
me here flip it and kill it you know
what I mean yeah he's definitely one of
those but I think if I had to think but
that was that was a little coming off of
my generation I think another one that's
super underrated is Tory Lanez Tori's
incredible he's another Beast yeah like
on a different level no his new album is
fire too you know like that kid never
missed me like he's really and he had to
always go against because he's fighting
that Canadian and then Drake is always
obviously the number one artist out
there and he's can't even he's also had
an interesting come up like people don't
know changed the course he was under
Sean Kingston for a little bit right he
kind of was like uh a behind the scenes
guy with the pen dropping his mixtapes
and like I feel like Tori's always had a
chip on his shoulder and you know not a
lot of people can drop independently and
so that'd be the number one album of the
week like he just did Notorious I think
his talent always supersedes people's
expectations that's fair I really
believe that know I think he does he
definitely did but I think the best that
ever did it of this time and me being
alive to see it was Drake yeah I
honestly believe that because it's
consistency to me was amazing yeah no
Drake's an alien yeah he's an alien for
sure he's the biggest rapper ever he's
the biggest I didn't say he's the
greatest but he's the biggest no he's
the biggest his uh honestly with that's
to be debated too because the I think as
far as him being the greatest I'm
talking about I'm talking about just the
the amount of time because I think Peak
but even if 50. even in the amount of
time he's still consistent no I'm saying
he's like it's not like we've never
looked at Drake since like 09 and said
yo are you falling off Drake never not
once like Drake's always got hits right
periods exactly successfully no one's
been as consistent and been that
[ __ ] for as long I think there's
been peaks in rap where people were
bigger like I think snooping 94 when
doggy style came out I think uh 50. Get
Rich or Die Tryin 50. I don't know man
that was something was a beast he's
that's another Beast just that G Unit
two years
first two years of the Jewish boy
Whoa he motivated me heavy like I like
oh I got something I can go after now we
gotta stop the interview tell you about
our partners at Odd Socks well first of
all let's check out the brand new collab
look at these the bootleg Kev sock you
see my pink ass face on those [ __ ]
socks nobody wants to buy those we're
gonna figure out a way to give them away
though uh but look Odd Socks the most
comfortable socks in the world
um and the best thing about Odd Socks is
they're our family man I've been rocking
with these guys for about 10 years now
and I will not wear anything else on my
feet like I swear to God I'm about to
take my shoe off I'm about to take the
look what is this
smells great too it's an odd sock right
there that's awesome basic you know what
I'm saying we [ __ ] with Odd Socks you
should too they got the crazy licenses
we're talking about Nickelodeon shout
out to Patrick [ __ ] Cheez-Its
Baywatch
how about macaroni underwear look at
these boys right here let's just crack
these [ __ ] open real quick what
do we got in here
come on man
yeah a little Pop-Tart underwear you
know what I mean yeah these are the Odd
Socks Basics all right so if you go to
the website right now order you some
underwear order you some socks use the
promo code bootleg Kev that's one word
altogether bootleg Kev and you will save
20 off at checkout go to
oddsocksofficial.com one more time
that's oddsocksofficial.com promo code
bootleg Kev and you will save 20 off
your order of course represented by Odd
Socks and we are proud to say so all
right let's get back to the interview
yeah um I just was speaking to a friend
of mine who just sold their life story
to FX for a TV show you have a pretty
amazing life story right considering
where you came from
um to where you are now would you ever
sell your life story for a movie purpose
or Netflix series or anything like that
I'm definitely planning on doing a life
story
um I don't know if I would sell it I
would park or produce it yourself I
wouldn't produce it myself either but I
would definitely partner with the right
producers to do it yeah because I feel
like we get
um you know certain stories like a
snowfall do you watch snowfall I love
snowfall it's great yeah a lot of people
say it's about Freeway Rick Ross right
but but exactly they can't technically
say because then they'd have to cut them
in a big check
[Laughter]
exactly somebody could [ __ ] around and
put out like a generic version of your
story yeah but I mean that's fine I mean
because even with music the way like
when I listen to today's music now I
know for a fact that we influenced a lot
of what you're hearing today yeah had we
not left we probably would have still
been consistent the same way Drake is
now but I see how the music has changed
from a standpoint of now RnB is rap
because I remember when I first dropped
rap was so serious that people were
battling it was about lyrics but then we
came and started singing what rappers
were rapping about and specifically you
right yeah I always like to say weed
because I never look at it like
I'm the because ghetto ghetto was one of
them once it's crazy because I told you
earlier I was like yo when I heard that
rap phenomenon mixtape and uh Green
Lantern did whatever remixed I thought
that was the original and then when I
got the album I was like wait wait
there's a whole other record it's a
whole other record but yeah you were
doing you were bringing the I feel like
you probably were the first person to do
that to bring the genres together
content wise right right and musically
right obviously Bone Thugs-N-Harmony was
very melodic but I wouldn't consider
them like they were making they were I
wouldn't consider bone in the discussion
I would say that like if you look at
nowadays the genres are so forged
together yeah like Futures making r b
sometimes like uh Roddy rich is making r
b records sometimes like so much of the
music is now just like it's just music
like it's rooted in hip-hop or it's
rooted in r b but yeah it's definitely
you know one thousand percent yo I love
where it's at yeah I love it too man so
do we have an idea when the album is
dropping um right now I'll probably
release the date for the album release
probably in the next few weeks next few
weeks yeah because I've been kind of
shuffling between do I want to drop it
in December of this year or I want to
drop it first of the following year and
just take that whole year and ride it
out yeah
um before you go can you share uh just
the the most interesting Gaga story you
had with her maybe maybe it was early on
maybe it was when she I don't know wore
a meat dress to the day I don't know
just give me like a crazy Gaga story you
haven't shared yet I think the probably
the craziest Gaga stories when we went
to San Francisco to push a record for
the first time and I remember we went to
this radio station and I was in the
radio artist I mean the radio DJ kept
asking me
um about what I got going on and I was
like yo you know
it's my new artist Gaga you know we
pushing it and they were like yeah yeah
but what do you got like yeah at the
time I said bro she's a new artist
you're Akon I'm like hold up I'm here
you ain't going nowhere but I need the
world to understand that this girl right
here is going to be the biggest artist
in the world right and he had this lick
on his face like
whatever wow but the beautiful part
about it was that he said the only way
that I can see that happening is if
obviously if she caters to the you know
um uh the gay community basically yeah
and so he was like so
speaking of you
what do you prefer
guys or girls
yes heard that yeah and right before she
can open him up I was like both
and she was like [ __ ] what the [ __ ] is
wrong with you serious I think she's
very curious she's colorful
I know she probably wanted to kill me at
that moment but at the same time she
kind of I think she knew exactly what I
was saying and they they kind of
elaborated on her and she had the best
answer and she was like yeah well you
know I I just I'm I'm just a free spirit
and I never said and the guy was like
see we can rock with you what's the plan
and they played her record right after
that I mean and it's in San Francisco
yes yeah the moment they played her
record it became number one on phones
the same day wow that's huge it was like
I mean she's an icon period but also an
icon in that Community right no no she
but then it was interesting because as
her career developed
that became one of her biggest like
movements is oh yeah they love that yeah
shout out shout out to the uh yeah the
the yeah
anyway uh listen man I appreciate you
pulling up I appreciate it thank you man
um go get the new album whenever it
comes out yes it's called iconic it'll
be coming out very very soon oh so we
got the name what is it iconic oh
instead of iconic I see what you did
there
I see what you did there Akon there it
is we got a coin there you go wait
what's the name of the city Akon city
acon city
you know you have a real theme going on
with these business ventures convict con
live everything got caught in it somehow
but
uh no actually the African uh side of
the philanthropy aspect is all energy
and of course we're building
um uh entertainment music schools now so
we're talking about schools that already
exists that's probably beat up or
whatever we refurbished them and make
them like put the conditions very
comfortable to where the kids can go in
there and actually have good education
but then we add musical curriculars in
it as well too uh last thing I promise
you are one of the most iconic Africans
of all time
Elon Musk also South Africa South Africa
have you guys linked up about any of
this [ __ ] you got going on interestingly
enough when I was doing the acon
lighting projects we actually met up
with Tesla to do
um the home
kits for those areas in Africa so we did
a line with Tesla but me and Elon
together haven't have you guys met at
all no we haven't met wow we haven't met
yeah his parents are probably the same
people though but we him have never met
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah because he's
from South Africa yeah that's crazy what
part are you from again I'm in West
Africa yeah damn yeah what is and it's
so crazy how Africa is so different
depending on what region you're in yeah
it's wild man well look I appreciate you
pulling up Akon the legend my man
appreciate you brother boom all right